tragic death of Aaron Carter his
toxicology report is still pending but
E.T has learned his body will be
released to his mother Jane in
preparation for his upcoming funeral
meanwhile Aaron's ex told me that she is
struggling to move on
the image of Melanie Martin sobbing
outside Aaron's home after his death is
heartbreaking the mother of their 11
month old son Prince says she is quote
not well haven't slept since it happened
she is in complete shock and denial
adding quote we really could not live
without each other E.T has also learned
Aaron missed a therapy appointment the
evening before he died
I had this like love triangle with
Hillary and Lindsay yeah what's up how
are you all these years later both of
Aaron's former girlfriends Hilary Duff
and Lindsay Lohan have made peace
Lindsay liked Hillary's online tribute
which said quote boy did my teenage self
love you deeply you guys all really came
up together as you know part of this
generation of these young Stars yeah I
just um you know my heart goes out to
his family and he rest in peace and God
bless him and yeah just a lot of love
there Aaron was also once a contestant
on Dancing With the Stars our Matt Cohen
was in the ballroom last night we want
to take a moment to remember a star who
competed on season nine
wow little Aaron Carter's all grown up
looking good
I know he was here with you guys back on
season it's a true tragedy because to me
it's like an innocent young child this
beautiful bright light that seemed to be
misunderstood and I felt like on Dancing
With the Stars he had this moment where
people could see him in his fullest
sense during dancing's 90s night a
double elimination sent Heidi demilio
and Vinnie guadalino ho we made it like
close to the end which is pretty crazy
this show was all that and a bag of
chips featuring live performances by En
Vogue Kid and Play Vanilla Ice and Salt
and Pepper
no one was feeling the 90s Vibes more
than Shangela and Wayne Brady
all right stop collaboration free 90s
concert
this was the most fun I've had on the
show everybody was energized tonight
[Music]